Hey, everyone. It's Roman Mars. And today I want to tell you about a special mini-series we're going to be running on 99% of Visible the next few weeks. It's a collaborative show we're making with WBUR's podcast about internet culture, endless thread. And here to help me introduce our special series is the host of Endless Thread, Ben Brock Johnson. Hey, Ben. Hey, Roman. So, Ben, you've been on our show before. Yeah, that's right. We work together on an episode. about the history is Fall Bar, the home of the global seed vault in Norway. You've also featured an episode from Endless Thread about the Punisher Skull and how that imagery is used by white supremacists. Yes, which continues to be relevant today. So I feel like our shows have always been Sympatico. And last year, you came to us with a really cool idea for a collaboration all about video games. Yeah, I'm so excited about this. It was really fun to work on with y'all.
大家好，我是罗曼·马斯。今天我想向大家介绍一个特别的迷你系列节目，我们将在接下来的几周里在《99%无形》（99% Invisible）中播出。这是一个我们与WBUR关于互联网文化的播客《无尽线索》（Endless Thread）合作制作的节目。为了帮助我介绍这个特别系列，我请来了《无尽线索》的主持人本·布洛克·约翰逊。你好，本。你好，罗曼。那么，本，你之前来过我们的节目。是的，没错。我们曾一起制作过一集关于斯瓦尔巴群岛历史的节目，那里是挪威全球种子库的所在地。你还曾推荐过《无尽线索》中关于“惩罚者”骷髅标志的一集，以及该图像如何被白人至上主义者所利用。是的，这在今天仍然具有现实意义。所以我感觉我们的节目一直很合拍。去年，你带着一个关于电子游戏的绝妙合作点子来找我们。是的，我对此感到非常兴奋。能和你们一起合作真的很有趣。
Roman, do you know what you call two people collaborating to beat a video game together? No. Is this like a riddle or is this like a real thing? It's a real question. It's called the couch co-op. Oh, okay. Okay. So we're sitting next to each other on the couch, like trying to defeat a level. Got it. That's right, man. You got the soda. I got the snacks. We're ready to go. Now, I am not a hardcore gamer. I mainly like play Solitaire on my phone or the New York Times puzzles each day. Yeah. How about you? I play several hours a week, I will admit. I'm in the Hell Divers 2 zone right now, playing that game a lot. But one of the things I love about your idea for this series is that it's all about how video
罗曼，你知道两个人合作通关一款电子游戏叫什么吗？不知道。这是个谜语还是真有其事？这是一个真正的问题。这叫“沙发合作”（couch co-op）。哦，好吧。所以我们坐在沙发上，并排坐着，试图通关一个关卡。明白了。没错，伙计。你拿汽水，我拿零食。我们准备好了。不过，我不是硬核玩家。我主要是在手机上玩纸牌游戏，或者每天做《纽约时报》的拼图。你呢？我承认，我每周会玩几个小时。我现在沉迷于《绝地潜兵2》，玩得很多。但我喜欢你这个系列点子的原因之一是，它讲述了电子游戏和游戏设计如何改变了游戏之外的世界。所以，无论你是像我这样的休闲玩家，还是像你这样的资深玩家，你都能从中获益良多。完全正确。我真的相信电子游戏有着非常有趣且巨大的影响力。我很高兴能揭晓这个系列。我们将我们的系列命名为“罗曼的隐藏关卡”（Roman Hidden Levels）。在这个系列中，我们有关于电子游戏塑造我们世界的多种方式的剧集。我们有一集是关于游戏史上最具标志性的声音之一。Boom-shakalaka。
games and video game design have changed the world beyond video games. So you could be a very casual gamer like me or a more serious one like you, and you will still get a lot out of it. That's exactly right. I really believe that video games have this really interesting and outsized impact. I'm very excited to reveal this. We are calling our series Roman Hidden Levels. So in our series, we've got episodes about the many ways video games shape our world. We've got an episode on one of the most iconic sounds in gaming history. Boom-shakalaka.
Boom-shakalaka。我们将讨论游戏如何重塑自然环境。我非常熟悉那种走在树林里的感觉，它以某种方式转化为了我在游戏中的体验。我们将讨论有史以来最受欢迎的游戏控制器的起源和演变。它有一种直接操控的特质。
Boom-shakalaka. We will discuss how games reshape the natural environment. I was so familiar with that feeling of, like, walking through the woods, that it kind of just translated into my experiences in game. We'll talk about the origins and evolution of the most popular. game controller ever. There's a kind of direct manipulation quality to it.
最后，我们还有一集“最终BOSS”剧集，我们认为你会喜欢的。世嘉（Sega）是挑战者，对吧？世嘉从来都不是王者。世嘉只是走到王者面前要求决斗。所以，秉承着真正的“沙发合作”精神，
And we got one final boss episode at the end that we think you're going to love. Sega was the challenger, right? Sega was never the king. Sega was just coming up to the king and asking for a fight. So in true couch co-op spirit,
这个节目将于10月7日在《99%无形》和《无尽线索》的订阅源中同步上线。但对于Serious XM Podcast Plus的订阅用户，你们现在就可以收听第一集了。所以，如果你还不是Serious XM Podcast Plus的订阅用户，请务必订阅，以便提前一周免费收听全部六集节目。另外，我很兴奋，罗曼。我们还将有两个额外的“支线任务”剧集。它们将在《无尽线索》的订阅源中播出。
this show hits both the 99PI feed and the endless thread feed available everywhere on October 7th. But for Serious XM Podcast Plus subscribers, you can actually listen to the first episode right now. So if you're not a Serious XM podcast plus subscriber, make sure you subscribe to get all six episodes ad-free and one week early. Also, I'm excited about this, Roman. We're going to have two extra SideQuest mission episodes. That's going to be in the endless thread feed.
再次重申，“隐藏关卡”将于10月7日在《99%无形》和《无尽线索》的订阅源中同步上线。希望你们喜欢。这里是《99%无形》，我是罗曼·马斯。去年我们花了不少时间制作了一个特别系列，深入剖析了罗伯特·卡罗所著的《权力掮客》，这是一部关于纽约市规划师罗伯特·摩西的精彩传记。《权力掮客》是一部非常完整的作品，但书的结尾并不是故事的终点。当《权力掮客》在1974年出版时，纽约市正处于崩溃边缘，其副标题《罗伯特·摩西与纽约的衰落》被广泛认为是事实。
So again, Hidden Levels hits both the 99% Invisible and the Endless Thread feed on October 7th. We hope you like it. This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. We spent a good chunk of last year on a special series breaking down the power broker by Robert Carrow, the incredible biography of New York City planner Robert Moses. The power broker is such a complete work, but the end of the book is not the end of the story. When the power broker was published in 1974, New York City was crumbling, and it's such Subtitle, Robert Moses and the Fall of New York, was widely accepted as truth.
罗伯特·卡罗在书中没能涵盖的是仅仅一年之后发生的事情。这座城市经历了一场可怕的金融危机。那场危机是一部名为《死城》（Drop Dead City）的新纪录片的主题，由迈克尔·罗哈坦和彼得·约斯特执导。片名指的是臭名昭著的《纽约每日新闻》头版标题，该标题是在时任总统杰拉尔德·福特发表讲话称联邦政府不会救助纽约之后刊登的。那个标题，
What Robert Carroll didn't get to cover in the book was just one year later. The city went through a terrible financial crisis. That crisis is the subject of a new documentary called Drop Dead City, directed by Michael Rohattan and Peter Yost. The title is a reference to the infamous New York Daily News front page headline published after then-President Gerald Ford made a speech saying that the federal government would not bail out New York. That headline,
“福特对纽约说：去死吧”（Ford to City, Drop Dead），是大多数人对整个事件的记忆，如果他们还记得的话。但故事远不止于此。《死城》非常出色且引人入胜，它很好地解释了当时的局势，
Ford to City, Drop Dead, is what most people remember about this whole saga, if they know anything at all. But there's a whole lot more to the story. Drop Dead City is excellent and compelling and does a great job explaining the situation,
采访了几乎所有仍在世的关键人物，并提供了一些关于1970年代纽约街道和1970年代纽约口音的精彩档案片段。它感觉像是《权力掮客》的尾声或下一章。所以我认为，像我们剖析《权力掮客》的每一章一样，来剖析这部电影会很有趣，
with interviews from nearly all the key players still around, and some fantastic archival footage of 1970s New York streets and 1970s New York accents. It sort of feels like a Coda slash next chapter to the power broker. So I thought it'd be fun to break the movie down like we did with each chapter of the power broker
并将其制作成《99%无形》剖析《权力掮客》的特别节目。这意味着，当然，我必须叫上我的联合主持人埃利奥特·凯林。那么，埃利奥特。是的，罗曼。当我们上次谈论《权力掮客》时，我们的角色身处何地，
and turn this into a special episode of the 99% of visible breakdown of the power broker. Which means, of course, I had to call up my co-host, Elliot Kaelin. So, Elliot. Yes, Roman. When we last talked about the power broker, where did we leave our characters
而纽约市又处于什么状态？我们离开时，纽约市表现得很好。它当时表现得非常棒。我们的老朋友罗伯特·摩西，那位名义上的权力掮客、总规划师，终于被赶下了台。正如书的最后一章所说，他老了，不再拥有权力。他对自己所做的一切塑造这座城市的工作，人们却表现出缺乏感激之情感到沮丧。
and where did we leave New York City? We left New York City doing great. It was just doing fantastic. fantastically well. Our old friend Robert Moses, the titular powerbroker, the master planner, he had been finally pushed out of office. He was, as the final chapter of the book says, old and no longer in power. He was frustrated by the lack of thankfulness and gratefulness that people were showing
为什么书结束时他们不感激他？他们不感激的原因之一，也是罗伯特·卡罗在书中如此不感激的原因，是因为他留下的纽约在经济上非常糟糕。这就是我认为我们中任何一个人，像我一样，像你们两位，罗曼，任何热爱1970年代纽约电影的人都非常熟悉的纽约，也就是我所说的“肮脏的纽约”。街道上到处都是垃圾，到处都是瘾君子。
for all the work he had done to shape this city. Why weren't they grateful as the book ends? One of the reasons maybe they were not grateful and why Robert Caro is so not grateful in the book is because he leaves the New York behind that it. is doing financially very poorly. And this is the New York that I think any of us, like myself, like I think you two, Roman, any of us who love the New York movies of the 1970s knows pretty well, which is what I would call grimy New York. The New York of there's garbage all over the streets. There's drug addicts everywhere.
地铁无法运行。这是一个拼命挣扎着为市民提供服务的纽约，而这些服务曾经被认为是理所当然的。你不能把这一切都归咎于罗伯特·摩西，但因为我们花了太多时间讨论他，所以很容易这样做。没错。这就引出了我们今天讨论的话题，至少是作为我们讨论核心的流行文化作品，即这部名为《死城》的电影，这是一部关于1970年代纽约金融危机以及随之而来的紧缩政策的纪录片。它确实为《权力掮客》副标题中的“纽约的衰落”设定了场景。它确实向你展示了罗伯特·卡罗想要表达的内容，以及他为什么如此愤怒。
The subways don't work. This was a New York that was desperately struggling to provide the level of service to its citizens. that it had taken for granted that it would be able to provide. And you can't blame all of this for Robert Moses, but it's so tempting to just because we spent so much time talking about it. That's right. And this brings us to what we're discussing today, at least the piece of pop culture that is, you know, centering our discussion, which is this movie called Drop Dead City, which is a documentary about the 1970s New York financial crisis and the sort of austerity that followed. And it really sets a scene of the fall of New York in the subtitle of the powerbroker. Like it really shows you what Robert Carroll was getting at and why he was so mad.
每当我们与他交谈时，我们都会问，也许，回顾过去，你觉得对罗伯特·摩西是否有点苛刻？他会说，不，如果说有什么的话，我对他是手下留情了。我对他太好了。这部电影最让我印象深刻的一点是，里面有大量关于纽约街景的精彩镜头，展示了当时的纽约是什么样子。你看着它，你会想，哦，这个纽约看起来正在崩溃，它在物理上分崩离析。即使是你看到的城市中不错的部分，因为有很多工会领袖和银行高管开车参加会议的场景，即使是好的部分看起来也病态。有一种可怕的、病态的70年代感觉。
And anytime we've ever talked to him where we go, maybe, you know, like in retrospect, do you think back, maybe a little harsh on Robert Moses? He's like, no, I was, if nothing, I went easy on him. I was too nice to him. One of the things that strikes me so much about this movie, there's so much great footage in it of just street scenes of New York, what New York looked at the time. And you look at it and you're like, oh, this New York looks like it is crumbling, that it's physically falling apart. And even the nice parts of the city that you see, because there's lots of scenes of union leaders and bank executives showing up in their cars at meetings. Even the nice parts look sickly. Like there's this kind of like horrible sickly 70s feel to it.
你会想，哦，是的。没错。就像如果一切都是橙色和棕色的，我其实挺喜欢的。但所有这些穿西装的家伙都留着长发。你只会想，我需要西德尼·吕美特滚开，别再给这个地方打光了，因为每个人看起来都太糟糕了。但你在观看时会明白，哦，如果这就是罗伯特·卡罗在完成《权力掮客》时所处的纽约。没错。因为他在八年前就开始写这本书了。
And you're like, oh, yeah. Yeah, exactly. It's like if this is the everything's orange and brown, I kind of like it. But all these guys who are in suits have very long hair. You're just like, I need Sidney Lament to get the fuck out of here and stop lighting this place because everyone looks horrible. But you understand while you're watching it, oh, if this is the New York that Robert Carroll is living in while he's finishing the power broker. Right. Because he started it, you know, eight years earlier.
如果这就是他完成这本书时所处的纽约，难怪他会生气。难怪副标题是“纽约的衰落”，因为纽约看起来确实在腐烂。你知道，它看起来，看起来太糟糕了。是的。所以这是这部电影中第一个引人注目的地方，那种视觉效果。我喜欢这部电影的另一个引人注目的地方是，纽约口音简直太疯狂了。我认为社交媒体等已经让文化变得扁平化，区域口音已经真正消失了，尤其是那种典型的纽约口音，因为孩子们在街上接受采访，谈论市长亚伯·比姆。
If this is New York he's living in while he's finishing it, no wonder he's mad. No wonder it's the fall of New York in the subtitle because New York looks like it is. and decay. You know, it looks, it looks just terrible. Yeah. And so that's the first striking thing in this movie, the sort of visuals of that. The other striking thing that I love about this movie is the New York accents are just out of control. We have flattened culture by, I think, social media and stuff of like regional accents have really fallen away, especially the sort of quintessential New York accent has really, like, diminished because kids are interviewed on the street, talking about Mayor Abe Beam.
我觉得这不公平。为什么人们会被解雇？嗯，市长说没有足够的钱付给他们。嗯，我不在乎他怎么说。他只是个愚蠢的老流浪汉。你知道，这太棒了。我喜欢它。这部电影立即以1975年纽约市的视觉和声音取悦了观众。太壮观了。我有同样的感觉，因为尽管我一直在说，哦，它在崩溃。城市正在分崩离析。但它仍然有一些非常吸引人的地方。
I think that's not fair. Why should people get laid off? Well, the mayor says there isn't enough money to pay him. Well, I don't care what he says. It's just a dumb old bum. You know, like, it's so fantastic. I love it. And the movie immediately delights with the visuals and the sound of New York City in 1975. It's spectacular. I feel the same way because as much as I was saying, oh, it's crumbling. The city is in, is falling apart. There's not still something so enticing about it.
也许这只是我内心那个拒绝彻底死去的年轻朋克，知道在这种衰落中会产生所有这些令人惊叹的事情。没错。但也许就像你说的，是因为口音太强烈了，城市里的人的个性和城市的个性太强烈了。而纽约，尽管我爱它，它有点“世界上最伟大的城市”，而且永远都是。它是一个感觉不再像曾经那样具有独特纽约风味的城市。这部电影最令人悲伤的一面是，当时的纽约在照顾市民方面遇到了困难。它在日常生活中挣扎，因为它没钱了，靠债务生活。但第二悲伤的部分是这种潜流，是的，情况很糟糕，但这个地方仍然有一些纽约的味道。
And maybe it's just the young punk in me that refuses to die all the way, knowing that there's going to be all these amazing things that come out of this decay, you know. That's right. But perhaps it's like you're talking about it's that the accents are so strong, the personality of the people in the city and the personality the city is so strong. Whereas New York, as much as I love it, it's a little greatest city in the world, and always will be. It's a city that does not feel as distinctly New York as it once once. And the saddest aspect of the movie is that New York at the time is having trouble taking care of its citizens. It's having trouble living day to day because it's running out of money and it's living on debt. But the second status part of it is this undercurrent of, yeah, things were bad, but there was still something New York about this place.
而引入的紧缩政策，为了让纽约在经济上重新站稳脚跟而投入的资金，不可避免地产生了你所说的扁平化效应，纽约不再是它自己，而是变成了全球金融之都，你知道，这并不是一个那么有趣的地方。嗯，没错。这是这部电影的一个大主题，也是这一时期任何历史的共同点，你知道，这是纽约市作为工人阶级城市的最后遗迹，大多数人都是工会成员。城市里有庞大的工人基础设施。他们可能买不起曼哈顿的房子，但他们可以在布鲁克林或皇后区买房。而这正是在这一时刻受到冲击，因为城市提供的所有这些服务，工会非常强大，
And the process of the austerity that was brought in, the money that was brought in to get New York back on its feet financially, inevitably has that flattening effect that you're talking about where New York stops being itself and becomes instead the global capital of finance, you know, which is not a, not as fun of place to be. Well, right. And that's a big theme of this movie and this sort of like any sort of history of this time period is, you know, this was the last vestige of New York City being a working class city where most people were part of a union. There was a large, you know, like infrastructure of workers in the city. They could afford maybe not to live in Manhattan, but they could buy a house in Brooklyn or Queens. And this is hitting at this moment where this is breaking. because there's all these city services that are being offered, and the unions are quite powerful,
他们为工会下的人们创造了美好的生活。但许多力量正在使它发生变化，比如城市的经济中心正在离开。所以，工厂正在离开城市。它们不再在那里了。白人正在离开城市。他们不再是税基了。而城市服务却在跟进，这进一步加剧了城市的财政问题。但事实证明，财政问题由来已久，只是没人知道，因为城市的账目做得一团糟。
and they've made a good life for the people who are underneath the unions. But many forces are making it so, like, the economic centers of the city are leaving. So, like, factories are leaving the city. They're no longer in place. White people are leaving the city. They're no longer there as a tax base. And city services are keeping up, and this is further complicating the financial problems of the city. But it turns out that the financial problems have been a long time coming, but nobody knew about him because the city kept horrible books.
他们没有一个合理的会计系统。这太混乱了。每个人都把东西塞在抽屉里。每个人都把各种东西埋起来。这其中总得有个好的结局吧。根本就没有账本。我之前在《权力掮客》播客中提到过，我最喜欢的电影是《地铁惊魂》（The Taking of Pelham One Two Three），
They didn't have an accounting system that made me sense. It was chaotic. Everybody had stuff in drawers. Everybody had buried and buried in various stuff. And there's got to be a good end to some of this. There were no fucking books. I've mentioned before on the Power Roker podcast. favorite movies that take in Pelham, one, two, three, the
1974年版。我喜欢它，但我在观看并喜欢它的同时，我心想，我很高兴我不必住在这个城市，也不必和这些在里面的人打交道。因为所有这些非常古怪、有趣、尖刻的纽约类型的人，可能不是最容易共事的人，
19774 edition. And I love it, but the whole time I'm watching it loving it, I'm like, I'm so glad I don't have to live in this city and deal with these people who are in it. Because all of these very kind of like, quaint, fun, abrasive New York types are probably not the easiest people to work with
或者在日常生活中打交道的人。伙计们，放轻松点，好吗？哦，得了吧。如果我因为他们让几个女人进来就得注意我的语言，我就要辞职了。你怎么能经营该死的铁路，但我会发誓。一个例子就是城市的簿记，这是一个已经存在了几百年的城市。而城市的簿记是不存在的。它基本上是以一个刚毕业的家伙做税收的方式运行的，他只有一堆皱巴巴的收据。
or deal with on a day-to-day basis. Guys, take it easy, will you? Oh, come on. If I got to watch my language, just because they let a few broads in, I'm going to quit. How to help can you run a goddamn railroad, but I'll swear. And an example of that is that the bookkeeping of the city, this is a city that's been around for hundreds of years by this point. And the bookkeeping on the city is non-existed. It's basically run the way that like a guy just out of college does his taxes where he just has a bunch of like crumpled receipts.
也许他打印了纳税表格。城市能做到这一点真是令人震惊，我想这确实是对纽约精神的一种致敬，在没人知道的情况下竟然做得这么好。任何事情花了多少钱，或者城市在任何给定时间有多少钱。你不能看账本说，预算是多少，债务是多少，赤字是多少，我们付给每个部门多少钱。相反，它只是各种流氓数字在不同人的脑海中和不同的纸片上漂浮。而这其中最令人惊奇的事情之一是，市长亚伯·比姆，他之前是审计长。所以他部分负责这个系统的混乱。因为他就是那个用纸片维持城市运转的家伙，你知道。
And maybe he, maybe he printed out the form to pay his taxes. And it's just astonishing the way that the city has done such a good, I guess it's a real tribute to the New York spirit that's done such a good job of surviving when nobody knows how. How much money is being spent on anything or how much money the city has at any given point. And you can't look at a ledger and say, here's what the budget is, here's what our debt is, here's what the deficit is, here's how much we're paying each of these departments. Instead, it's just various rogue numbers floating around in different people's heads and on different scraps of paper. And one of the amazing things about this is that the mayor who this is going to fall on the hardest, a beam, he was the comptroller beforehand. So he's partly responsible for how disorganized the system. Because he was the guy who was keeping the city afloat using scraps of paper, you know.
嗯，他在这里的受害者，为什么他最后被抓住了，是因为有几百年的做事方式。这没问题，因为城市太庞大了，现金流太大了，以至于它可以掩盖任何交易处于账目的哪一边。就像如果有钱流过，这并不重要。你一直在借钱，一直在负债，但你总是把钱给出去。每个人都以某种方式得到报酬，它以某种方式运作。特别是在二战结束时，当纽约是一个主要的制造业中心时，它是世界各地的人们来工作的地方。它充满了钱。是的，钱就在里面流转。
Well, what he's a victim of here, why he's sort of caught holding the bag at the end, is there was a way of doing things for a couple hundred years. And it was fine because the city was so massive that the cash flow was so great that it could mask what side of the leisure any sort of, you know, transaction was on. Like if there's money flowing through, it doesn't really matter. You're kind of constantly borrowing, you're constantly in debt, but you're always given money out. And everyone kind of gets paid somehow, and it kind of works. Especially at the end of World War II, when New York is a major manufacturing center, it's the place people from all over the world are coming to to do work. And it's just a, it's flush with money. Yeah, there's just money flowing through it.
所以就像，哦，卫生部门的账单来了。嗯，这是我在抽屉里找到的10块钱。你可以用那个。哦，太棒了，太棒了。我们得付钱给这些老师。等一下。是的，这是这边的钱。这一切都非常“泥泞”。这一切都非常“泥泞”，确实就是这样。所以这种借钱的习惯由来已久。事实上，可能他们是被罗伯特·摩西教导的，比如在
So it's like, oh, the bill on the sanitation came through. Well, here's, here's 10 bucks I found in a desk drawer. You can use that. Oh, great, great. We got to pay these teachers. Hold on a second. Yeah, here's some money over here. It's all very, it's very slushy. It's all very slushy is very much the way it is. And so this habit of borrowing money, this has been a long time coming. In fact, it's possible that they were kind of taught this by Robert Moses, like in terms of
发行债券、资助项目，然后偿还它们方面。所以，从《权力掮客》这本书来看，你把那种为了服务而借钱的开始放在哪里，这似乎是导致这里衰落的开始。所以我认为你是对的，罗伯特·摩西的大政策是你发行债券来支付大型基础设施改善，为了桥梁，为了隧道。通行费偿还你，你偿还债券持有人，它变成了一个永恒的、永久的印钞机。当瓦格纳市长担任纽约市长时，出现了资金缺口。
making bonds available, funding things, and then paying them back. So, you know, from the Powerbroker book, where do you place the beginning of the sort of borrowing money for services that seems to be the sort of the thing that starts the downfall here. So I think you're right that Robert Moses, his big policy is you issue a bond to pay for a big infrastructure improvement, for a bridge, for a tunnel. The tolls pay you back and you pay the bondholders and it becomes a constant eternal perpetual money machine. And when Mayor Wagner is mayor of New York, there's a funding shortfall.
这是第一次，城市本身在发行债券。它现在借钱不是为了支付一笔大的资本改善账单，不是为了新事物，比如桥梁、隧道、体育场或水族馆之类的东西。那是一次性费用，会自行偿还。但他们第一次借钱是为了支付城市的日常开支。这被视为一件不寻常的事情，我们不会养成这种习惯。税收收入会进来。我们会还清它。
And for really the first major time, the... The city itself is now issuing a bond. It's now borrowing money in order to pay not just a big capital improvement bill, not a new thing, like a bridge or a tunnel or a stadium or an aquarium or something like that. That's a one-time fee that will pay itself off. But they're borrowing money for the first time to cover the day-to-day expenses of the city. And this is seen as an out of the ordinary thing, we are not going to make a habit out of this. The tax revenues are going to come in. We're going to pay it off.
我们要在纸上和亚伯·比姆口袋里的纸片上平衡这些账目。你知道，然后当约翰·林赛市长在瓦格纳之后上任时，纽约支付这些账单变得更加困难，借钱成为了一件常事。现在纽约突然像许多普通美国人一样靠信用卡生活，它靠借来的钱生活，而且永远无法完全还清那笔钱。所以当亚伯·比姆担任市长时，这已经追上了纽约，它不能再在不偿还所欠资金的情况下继续借钱了。而且它支付债务利息的钱太多了，以至于预算中越来越大的一部分仅仅被用来偿还之前借的债务。他们一直说，嗯，税收收入会进来的。我们会有一段充裕的时间，然后我们会还清一切，这就像经典的拉斯维加斯赌徒成瘾谈话。这基本上就像罗伯特·德尼罗主演的《盗火线》，就像最后一次大抢劫。
We're going to balance these books on the sheets of paper and air and a beam's pocket. You know, and then when Mayor John Lindsay comes in after Wagner, it becomes much more of a problem for New York to meet those bills and becomes a regular thing to borrow money. Now suddenly New York is living on its credit card the way that so many average everyday Americans do, where it is living on borrowed money and it can never fully pay off that money. And so by the time Abe Beam is mayor, that has caught up with New York, it can no longer continue to borrow money without paying off the money at owes. and it's paying so much to service the debt that a larger and larger portion of its budget is being used just to pay off previous debt that it borrowed. And they keep saying, well, and the tax revenues will come in. We're going to have a flush time and then we'll pay everything off, which is, it's like classic Vegas gambler addiction talk. It was like Heat with Robert De Niro basically, where it's like just one last big score.
你知道，然后他们就完成了。那是维尔科姆伯。然后我们就完成了。你知道，只是最后一次抢劫。但一切都变得非常糟糕。电影《盗火线》的剧透，大抢劫并没有像他们想要的那样发生，你知道。这也反映在州预算中。纳尔逊·洛克菲勒，那种东北部的自由派共和党人，你知道，现在已经不存在了，也是一个相当大的支出者，喜欢提供服务，你知道，我认为是一个有良好道德指南针的人。我对他没有任何反对意见，你知道，但也是一个支出者，并为通过州政府提供给纽约人的服务感到自豪。所以这一切，这只是当时的习惯和纽约的习惯？不仅仅是在纽约。这是城市、州和联邦。这是1960年代的时代。这是“伟大社会”的时代。我们处于二战后，美国在说，我们，世界上最强大的国家，怎么能有穷人呢？
You know, then they'll be done. That's Velcomber. Then we'll be done. You know, just one last score. But everything goes terribly. Spoiler for the movie, Heat, the big heist doesn't go off the way they want it to, you know. And this is also reflected in the state budget as well. Nelson Rockefeller, the sort of northeast liberal Republican, which, you know, doesn't really exist anymore, was also quite a spender, liked to provide services, was, you know, I think a man with a good moral compass. I have no objections to him greatly, you know, but like, but also was a spender and took a lot of pride in the services that were provided to New Yorkers through the state government. So all of this, this was just the habit of the time and the habit of New York? Not just in New York. This was city, state, and federal. This is the era of the 1960s. It's the time of the great society. We are post-World War II, and America is saying, how can we, the most powerful country in the world, have poor people?
我们怎么能有饥饿的人呢？我们必须照顾每个人。这是最好的意图，他们的雄心壮志在如何做到这一点上变得越来越大。不幸的是，经济力量发生了变化，时代发生了变化，突然间他们不再那么有钱了。而且很难让我们回到那种心态，因为在过去的40年里，我们生活在美国，压倒性的意识形态一直是：我们不能在服务上花钱。这是我们不能花太多钱的事情，而在1960年代，情况恰恰相反。纽约的危机是将其从一个转变为另一个的重大转折点之一。
How can we have hungry people? We have to take care of everybody. And it is the best of intentions and their ambitions become larger and large about how to do this. And unfortunately, economic forces change, time changes, and suddenly they're not as flush with money. And it's very hard to put ourselves back in that mindset since for the past 40 years we've lived in America where the overriding ideology has been we've got to not spend money on services. This is the thing that we cannot spend much money on, whereas in the 1960s it was the exact opposite. And the crisis in New York was one of those big tipping points in turning one from the other.
没错。我的意思是，直到这一点，或者也许特别是在这段时间里，有一种感觉，即与大型制造商、银行家和富人之间存在一种社会契约，即为了建立一个社会，我们都投入其中，为每个人创造一个更美好的世界。我想我会称之为“我们都生活在同一个国家”的契约，这已经不存在了。但在某个时刻，这在60年代和70年代开始了一点点，富人和权势者被提供了离开的出口，不必尽自己的一份力量。你知道，突然之间，“伟大社会”的经济基础，就像轮子掉了，因为，你知道，富人只是说，不，我不付钱。我要搬出城市。或者我要把我的工厂搬到特拉华州或德克萨斯州之类的。突然之间，当你不再拥有那个时，
That's right. I mean, there was a sense up until this point, or maybe just especially during this time, that there was a social contract with the big manufacturers and bankers and rich people that to make a society we all pitched in to create a better world for everybody. I think I would call it the we all live in the same country, compact, which no longer exists. But at a certain point, in this sort of starts in this little bit in the 60s and the 70s, there's off ramps afforded the rich and the powerful to not put in their part. You know, like, and all of a sudden, the economic underpinnings of the great society, like the wheels come off because, you know, rich people just kind of go, no, I'm not paying for that. I'm going to move out of the city. or I'm going to move my factory to Delaware or Texas or something. And all of a sudden, when you don't have that anymore,
这个建立在金钱流转和富人没有尽可能多地榨取基础上的良性循环系统，现在他们几乎是排他性地榨取。这是这一切的开始。所以整个系统就像，不仅仅是有过度支出的自由派。就像我们与每个人都有一个社会契约，我们都在让世界变得更美好。税收反映了这一点，人们没有把工厂搬离人们居住的地方，也反映了这一点。这一切都建立在这个系统上，然后这一切都分崩离析了。
this system that's all built on a virtuous cycle of money coming through and the rich people not extracting as much as they can, and now they extract almost exclusively. This is the very beginning of that. And so this whole system is like it's not just that there's overspending liberals. It's like we had a social contract with everybody that we were all making the world a better place. And the taxes reflected that and people not moving their factories out away from where people lived, reflected that. It was all built on this system and it all comes apart.
这是这部电影《死城》的一个大张力，就像纽约财政危机中的一个断点是出售银行随后会竞标然后卖给客户的市政债券的想法。有一种过度支出的感觉，破产就在地平线上，银行决定，我们不会买你们的债券。它曾经是竞争性的，他们会竞标，然后他们会分配它们。突然之间，城市如何支付自身费用和支付服务费用的系统中的这个齿轮开始崩溃，因为银行决定他们不想承担支持这些债券的风险，因为他们不知道税收是否会进来。他们怀疑这一点是对的，因为税收并没有进来。并不是他们错了。只是直到这一点，每个人之间都有一个共同的虚构。对于亚伯·比姆来说，这一定非常奇怪，他是市长，他之前是审计长，然后成为市长。
And this is a big tension of this movie, Drop Dead City, is like one of the breaking points in the sort of the fiscal crisis of New York is this idea of selling the municipal bonds that the banks would then bid on and then sell to their customers. and there's this sense of the overspending the bankruptcy is on the horizon, and the banks decide, we're not going to buy your bonds. And it used to be a competitive, and they'd bid on it, and then they would parcel them out. And all of a sudden, this gear in the system of how the city pays for itself and pays for the services just starts to break down because the banks decide they do not want to take the risk of supporting these bonds because they do not know if the tax money is going to come in. They are right to be skeptical of it because the tax money is not coming in. It's not that they're wrong. It's just that up until this point that there was a shared fiction among everyone. It must have been just completely weird for A. Beam, who is the mayor, who was the comptroller and becomes the mayor.
而新的审计长名叫哈里森·戈尔登。他进行了独立审计。他只是说，账本不存在。没人知道谁在赚什么。银行开始提出更难的问题，关于这些债券的收入是否真的会被支付，在某种程度上，你知道，比姆感到被攻击了。如果这是安然公司，戈尔登会是英雄，他会是举报人，但这不是安然，这是纽约市，而且很多人住在那里，所以风险更大，这令人担忧，而且比姆，故事中有很多是一个世代更替的故事，在某种程度上，比姆对我来说是一个迷人的人物，部分原因是他是一个在很多方面都非常不迷人的人。他是个矮个子，五英尺二英寸。他是个矮小的家伙。
And the new comptroller is named Harrison Golden. He does this independent audit. And he's just like, the books don't exist. Nobody knows what anyone's making. the banks begin to like ask questions that are harder questions about whether or not the income coming in from these bonds is actually going to be paid and in a way you know beam felt attacked it's the kind of thing where if this was anron golden would be a hero he'd be a whistleblower but it's not enron it's new york city and it's a lot of people live there like so it's so there's much more at stake that's fraught and and beam it there's so much the story that is a a story of changing generations in a way beam is a fascinating character to me partly because he is a very un-fascinating person in a lot of ways. He's a short king, five-two. He's this short little guy.
他是老派政治家。他通过机器崛起。他崛起于你是选区领导人，确保你所在地区的人在圣诞节有食物吃的日子。这家伙需要一份工作。好吧，我会拉关系帮你找份工作。现在他成为了一个新世界里的市长，那种极其超本地化的政治已经被最小化，或者可能被一切的互联性蒸发了，你知道，
He's an old-school politician. He came up through the machine. He came up in the days when you were award leader and you made sure that the people in your area had food on Christmas. This guy needs a job. Okay, I'll pull some strings to get you a job. And now he has become mayor in a new world where that kind of extremely hyper-local politics has been minimized or maybe vaporized by the interconnectedness of everything, you know,
以及通过新的做事方式和更专业的做事方式，以及期望比他习惯的、他崛起的方式更专业、更企业化治理水平的银行。我忍不住在脑海中把他与他之后的市长进行比较，特别是我住在纽约的时候。他与迈克尔·布隆伯格市长截然相反，布隆伯格担任了三届市长，非常像是一个“我是亿万富翁，我经营一家公司，我现在要像一个经营公司的亿万富翁希望纽约被经营的那样经营纽约”，而亚伯·比姆非常像是一个从底层崛起的人，说，“我要尝试像一个底层的人可能希望的那样经营城市”，这是一个我们试图给每个人他们需要或想要的东西，而我们不那么担心偿还银行家。而在历史上，他这样做并不是时候。所以城市依赖于银行家，
and by new ways of doing things and more professional ways of doing things, and banks that expect a more professional, more corporate level of governance than what he's used to, what he came up through. And I couldn't help compare him in my mind with the mayors that came after him, specifically when I was living in New York. And he's very much the opposite of Mayor Michael Bloomberg, who was mayor for three terms and was very much the, I'm a billionaire, I ran a corporation, I'm now going to run New York the way that a billionaire who runs a corporation would like New York to be run, whereas Abe Beam was very much a guy who came up from the bottom and said, I'm going to try to run the city the way that a guy from the bottom might want it to be run, which is one where we try to give everybody the things that they need or want, and we don't worry as much about paying off bankers. And it just wasn't the right time in history. for him to be doing that. So the city is dependent on the bankers,
认为城市在财务上足够稳健，可以再次开展业务。银行家们想要削减各种城市服务，以便他们对投资城市感到满意。银行和城市之间的主要摩擦点之一，在
thinking that the city is financially sound enough to do business with again. And the bankers wanted all sorts of city services cut for them to feel okay about investing in the city. And one of the main friction points between the banks and the city, in
纽约市立大学（CUNY）是城市的公立大学系统。自1847年成立以来，它一直免学费。亚伯·比姆是纽约市立大学的毕业生。他一直说，如果不是因为免学费，我就不会在这里。我就不会成为市长。它成为了银行家眼中纽约做错事的象征，他们认为他们可以给城市里的每个人提供免费大学教育。
CUNY is the city's public university system. And it had been tuition-free since its founding in 1847. And A. Beam is a graduate of CUNY. And he says all the time, I wouldn't be here. I wouldn't be mayor if it wasn't for free tuition. And it becomes such a symbol of to the bankers of what New York is doing wrong, they think they can give free college to everybody in the city.
这太疯狂了。向他们收取学费。而普通的，我本来想说普通市民。让我们说纽约的低工资市民相信，城市是一个共享的地方，欠他们服务，并且在那里帮助他们提升地位，或者帮助他们的孩子提升地位。这是关于生活在城市意味着什么的两种相互竞争的观点，
This is insane. Charge them tuition. And what the normal, I was going to say normal citizens. What the, let's say lower wage citizens of New York believe, which is that the city is this shared place that owes services to them and which is there to help them to rise up in their status or their children to rise up in their station. And it is two competing views of what it means to live in a city
以及成为美国人意味着什么。城市大学成为了这场斗争的焦点。它成为了银行和联邦政府变得非常反感的东西，几乎是这样。就像他们很生气。他们一直说，难道你不明白吗，你必须收取学费，因为那将向世界表明你对紧缩是认真的。它成为了仅仅是关于治理城市意味着什么的两种不同观点的断裂点，你知道，它们在这一刻陷入了危机。
and what it means to be American. And the city university just becomes this locus point of the fight. And it becomes something that the banks and the federal government become very offended by almost. Like they're angry. And they keep saying, don't you see, you have to charge tuition because that will show the world that you're serious about being austere. And it becomes such a fracture point for just two different views of what it means to
绝对是。当你听到这作为争论的一个要点时，令人震惊的一点是奥弗顿之窗（Overton window）已经向银行家的观点转移了多少。现在争论的是政府是否应该帮助人们支付他们欠下的数十万美元的大学学费，而不是政府应该允许他们免费上大学。看着它并阅读之后的一些补充材料，这真是一件令人震惊的事情。这是一个令人震惊的愿景，在不同的时代，各种服务被
govern a city, you know, which are coming into crisis at this moment. Absolutely. And one of the things that's striking when you hear that as a main point of argument is how much the Overton window has shifted towards the banker's point of view. Now the argument is whether the government should help people to pay the hundreds of thousands of dollars that they owe in college rather So then, rather than the government should allow them to go to college for free. It's really, it's a, it's an astonishing thing watching it and reading a little bit of supplementary materials afterwards. It was just such an astonishing vision of a different time when various services were
仅仅被认为是纽约市将提供的理所当然的事情。并不是美国每个人都得到了这个，但纽约市认为这是理所当然的。这是生活在城市的一部分，你得到这些东西。这让你想知道，权衡是城市没钱了，街道上到处都是垃圾。但这是一个经常在我脑海中闪过的权衡，作为一个在那个不同时代，朱利安尼之后，布隆伯格担任市长时住在纽约的人，当时城市的契约似乎是，你将来到这里，你将为你公寓支付比你认为应该支付的更多的钱。你将尽可能努力地工作。
just taken for granted as things that the New York City will provide. And it wasn't like everybody in America was getting this, but that New York City took it for granted. This is part of living in the cities you get these things. And it makes you wonder, the tradeoff is that then the city is running out of money and there's garbage all over the streets. But it's a trade-off that often rums through my mind as someone who lived in New York during that different time, post-Juliani, when Bloomberg was mayor, when the city contract seemed to be, you are going to come here, you're going to spend way more money than you think you should for your apartment. You're going to work as hard as possible.
城市会把你嚼碎并吐出来。但城市也是安全的，而且相对干净。它仍然很臭。就像城市仍然闻起来很糟糕，我的孩子们每次我们访问时都会评论这一点。但认为你可以理所当然地认为你可能不会被抢劫，你的建筑物可能不会被烧毁的想法。而在70年代，这几乎是相反的。几乎就像纽约进入了这个地方，就像，你可以上大学，你会有所有这些服务，但你也可能被抢劫，你可能被刺伤，你可能被困在火灾中。城市到处都会很肮脏。
The city is going to chew you up and spit you out. But the city is also safe and it's relatively clean. It still stinks. Like the city still smells really bad, which my children always comment on every time we visit. But the idea that you can take it for granted that you're probably not going to get mugged, your building's probably not going to burn down. Whereas in the 70s, it was almost like the opposite. It was almost like New York was entering this place where it was like, you can go to college, you'll have all these services, but it's also possible that you may get mugged, you may get stabbed, you might get caught in a fire. The city is going to be filthy all over the place.
我的意思是，它仍然有点肮脏，但这只是展示了一个，我想，看待它的方式是，我想是不同的优先事项，你知道。所以这是城市在财务上如何运行的一个真正的转折点，关于什么是服务，你知道，只是标准的，哪些是深远的，你知道，就像，我们今天认为在所提供的东西方面是白日梦的东西。有趣的是，纳尔逊·洛克菲勒辞职了，不再是州长。感觉比姆是最后一个老卫队，某种程度上在坚持，每个人都像，就像，让他负责在一定程度上。洛克菲勒说，我想我会成为美国副总统。我会让你处理
I mean, it's still kind of filthy, but it just shows a, I guess, the way to look at is, I guess, as different priorities, you know. And so this is a real inflection point in how the city is wrong. on financially, the sort of mindset of what services are, you know, just standard and which are far-reaching and, you know, like, what we would consider be kind of pipe dreams today in terms of what is being offered. And what's funny is, Nelson Rockefeller resigned and is no longer governor. It feels like Beam is the last, the old guard kind of like holding on and everyone's like, like, leaving him responsible to a certain extent. Rockefeller's like, I think I will be vice president of the United States. I'll let you deal
这个。所以休·凯里是新州长。他也只是像，他一直都是其中的一部分。而且可能，再次，有点措手不及。但就像，你的意思是什么？我们应该就这样做。为什么现在是个问题？你知道我的意思吗？
with this. And so Hugh Carey is the new governor. And he's also just like, he's been part of this the whole time. And it probably, again, was kind of blindsided. But like, what do you mean? We should just do this this way. And why is it a problem now? You know what I mean?
就是这样。休·凯里成了新任州长。他其实一直都参与其中。他可能再次感到措手不及。但他会想，这是什么意思？我们本来就该这么做。为什么现在成了问题？你明白我的意思吗？
And really does not want to be the last one, you know, without a chair in musical chairs. But it all comes down, like the independent audit by Golden, this realization that, oh, you know, there's a sense of like maybe we're like one or two billion dollars in debt. And it turns out they're more like $6 billion in debt. It feels like every time they do an audit, they find out that they are $2 billion more in debt than they were before. Like, I don't know how expensive these audits were. But yeah, they keep thinking like it'll be a little bit of a shortfall, but we'll be able to patch it up. And then they keep realizing how much bigger and bigger the bill is than they think it is. How much the city has been borrowing to cover its debt and how much it spends on things, how much it's not taking in in terms of taxes.
而且真的不想成为最后一个，你知道，在抢椅子游戏中没有椅子坐的人。但这一切归根结底，就像高登（Golden）进行的独立审计一样，人们意识到，哦，你知道，我们可能欠债一二十亿美元。结果发现他们欠债高达60亿美元。感觉每次他们进行审计，都会发现债务比之前又多了20亿美元。我不知道这些审计有多昂贵。但确实，他们一直以为只是小额缺口，我们能补上。然后他们不断发现账单比他们想象的要大得多。城市为了偿还债务借了多少钱，在各项事务上花了多少钱，以及在税收方面少收了多少钱。
It's really, I have to admit, I started getting very stressed just hearing about it in the movie. And this happened 50 years ago, and I wasn't involved. So I was just like, oh, how are they going to get at this one? They never will, you know? And the sort of the shaky confidence is sort of like the idea of people are not very confident about the city and its debt and its finances is getting to the bankers. They're not buying the bonds anymore. That money coming in from buying the bonds was what was paying off the old bonds, which had been, you know, like set up decades before. And there's these series of crises in sort of 1975, which is like,
我必须承认，在电影里听到这些时，我开始感到非常紧张。这发生在50年前，我并没有参与其中。所以我当时想，哦，他们该怎么解决这个问题呢？他们永远也解决不了，对吧？那种动摇的信心，就像人们对城市及其债务和财政状况缺乏信心一样，正在影响银行家们。他们不再购买债券了。通过购买债券流入的资金，正是用来偿还几十年前发行的旧债券的。在1975年左右发生了一系列危机，就像是，
oh, we're going to have a bunch of bonds due where we have to pay them off to the people who own them. And if we don't have the money, we're going to default. And at first, it's sort of like $10 million is due in like seven days and we have to do something about it. The bills always seem to be coming up in just a few days, as if, like, no one was keeping a calendar of this at any point. There's always a bunch of bills that are coming up almost instantly, and they continually have to find ways to deal with it. And they're only ways to raise more money or to make cuts. And so there's a quick reaction to all this, like, at first, which is like there's these construction projects and Beam just stops construction projects. So, okay, so this is begin, like, it's like, if we can't afford stuff, we can't do it, we can't pay the construction workers.
哦，我们有一堆债券到期了，必须偿还给持有人。如果我们没有钱，就会违约。起初，就像是七天内有1000万美元到期，我们必须采取行动。账单似乎总是在几天内就到期了，就好像从来没有人记录过这些日期一样。总有一堆账单几乎立刻就要到期，他们必须不断寻找应对方法。而他们唯一的方法就是筹集更多资金或进行削减。所以对这一切有一个快速反应，起初，就像有一些建设项目，比姆（Beame）直接停止了这些项目。所以，好吧，这就是开始，就像是，如果我们负担不起，我们就不能做，我们付不起建筑工人的工资。
And so the first, you know, the construction workers, which are a nicely paid, you know, contingent of the electorate, all of a sudden don't have projects to work on. And so they get angry first, you know what I mean? And the things that are deteriorating begin deteriorating even more. And then there's a round of like laying off workers and there's even like a layoff of cops, which is, has never happened before in the city of New York. Apparently there only been more and more cops over time up until that point. It was a real growth industry was policing in New York. And the cops go, they have this big protest action where they're shutting down a bridge. Like you have police officers off duty protesting who are getting into fights with police officers that are there to try to.
所以首先，你知道，建筑工人，这是一个薪水不错的选民群体，突然之间没有项目可做了。所以他们首先感到愤怒，你明白我的意思吗？那些正在恶化的事物开始进一步恶化。然后是一轮裁员，甚至还有警察裁员，这在纽约市以前从未发生过。显然，在那之前，警察人数一直在增加。在纽约，警务确实是一个增长行业。警察们进行了大规模的抗议活动，封锁了一座桥梁。就像你看到下班的警察在抗议，并与试图维持秩序的在职警察发生冲突。
keep the piece on duty. And I mean, the term powder keg gets thrown around a lot. But I think that was the fear at the time was if New York defaults, you're going to get even more of this, that it's such a powder keg that we're going to have to fire cops and they're going to be, you know, rioting. We're going to have to fire sanitation workers and the garbage is going to pile up. We're going to have to fire firefighters at a time when there's fires constantly in the city because there are abandoned buildings going up in flames. There are landlords who are getting buildings off of their hands by lighting them on fire. And all these very basic services and the people who are being cut are not like, oh, well, I guess it's time for me to go pick up the skills for another job. No, they could react very angrily, you know, and there's a feeling of, but we're supposed to have the power in this relationship because we're these powerful unions. And it becomes, to a certain extent, if I can use the term pissing match on this podcast, but it becomes a little bit of one of those. But just these things that the city has not seen in a long, long time. And the fear is, if we
维持秩序。我的意思是，“火药桶”这个词经常被提及。但我认为当时的恐惧是，如果纽约违约，这种情况会更多，它就像一个火药桶，我们将不得不解雇警察，然后他们会发生骚乱。我们将不得不解雇环卫工人，垃圾会堆积如山。我们将不得不解雇消防员，而当时城市里火灾不断，因为废弃的建筑物正在起火。有些房东通过放火烧毁建筑物来摆脱这些房产。所有这些非常基础的服务，而那些被裁减的人并不是说，哦，好吧，我想是时候去学习另一份工作的技能了。不，他们的反应可能会非常愤怒，你知道，有一种感觉是，我们本应在这段关系中拥有权力，因为我们是这些强大的工会。在某种程度上，如果我可以在这个播客中使用“撒尿比赛”这个词，它确实变得有点像那样。但这只是城市在很长很长一段时间内没有见过的事情。恐惧在于，如果我们
cut all these services, then the city is going to be. It's going to turn into bedlam. People are just going to riot and rise up. But also, if we don't make these cuts, the city is going to default, in which case everyone's going to lose their job. And it's the city's going to rise up and it'll be riots and become violent if these things happen. The police union really pushes this narrative. And they even launch a propaganda campaign where off-duty cops go to bus terminals and they pass out pamphlets to tourists that say, like in big letters, welcome. to Fear City with a grim reaper in the middle, and underneath it, it said, a survival guide for visitors to the city of New York. All these tips where it's like, don't leave your hotel room after dark. Do not ride the subways. Like, they're really raising the level of paranoia among travelers especially because what they're trying to do is they're trying to say, if we're not on duty, we are going to cut off the tourism to New York City that amazingly, even at this time when New York City was crumbling, was still pretty big business. That's the thing that's astounding to me is that New York is an enormous city. What's happening in one side of the city is so different from what's happening on the other side of the city. That what's happening in the South Bronx is so different from what's happening in Greenwich Village, which is so different from what's happening in Flushing Queens.
削减所有这些服务，那么城市就会陷入混乱。人们只会暴动和起义。但同样，如果我们不进行这些削减，城市就会违约，那样每个人都会失业。如果这些事情发生，城市就会起义，变得暴力。警察工会确实在推行这种叙事。他们甚至发起了一场宣传运动，下班的警察去巴士总站，向游客散发传单，上面用大字写着“欢迎来到恐惧之城”，中间画着死神，下面写着“纽约市游客生存指南”。上面有各种建议，比如天黑后不要离开酒店房间。不要乘坐地铁。他们确实在加剧旅行者的偏执，尤其是因为他们试图说，如果我们不在岗，我们将切断纽约市的旅游业，令人惊讶的是，即使在纽约市摇摇欲坠的时候，这仍然是一项相当大的业务。这让我感到震惊的是，纽约是一个巨大的城市。城市一侧发生的事情与另一侧发生的事情截然不同。南布朗克斯发生的事情与格林威治村发生的事情截然不同，与法拉盛皇后区发生的事情也截然不同。
Like, it's an enormous city. But you see this footage of garbage in the streets, old buildings, just crumbling, just empty lots of rubble that children are playing in and getting hurt in. And at the same time, it's still, people still want to go to New York and visit it. Like, they still want to see the Empire State Building and Times Square. And even though Times Square is full of, at that point, just kind of like porn theaters and shooting galleries and things like that. Like, they still want to go see these things. And the police are, they want to present the idea that without, if you don't rehire these police, without this police presence, the city will just be the most dangerous, frightening place in the world. Meanwhile, the city is trying to figure out where it's going to get all this money.
就像，这是一个巨大的城市。但你看到街头垃圾、旧建筑正在崩塌、孩子们在玩耍并受伤的空地碎石的镜头。与此同时，人们仍然想去纽约参观。他们仍然想看帝国大厦和时代广场。尽管当时的时代广场到处都是色情影院、射击场之类的东西。他们仍然想去看看这些东西。而警察，他们想传达这样一个观点：如果没有这些警察，没有这种警力存在，这个城市将成为世界上最危险、最可怕的地方。与此同时，城市正在试图弄清楚从哪里弄到这么多钱。
So they approach the federal government. So Nixon had resigned a year earlier and Gerald Ford is now the president. And like we mentioned, former New York governor, Nelson Rockefeller, had gotten himself appointed as vice president. And the secretary of treasury was William Simon, who had been a New York City bond salesman. So, like, they knew exactly what had been going on in the city. You would think, you would think the vice president used to be our governor. The secretary of the treasury used to work here. This will be super easy.
所以他们接触了联邦政府。尼克松在一年前辞职了，杰拉尔德·福特现在是总统。正如我们提到的，前纽约州州长纳尔逊·洛克菲勒被任命为副总统。财政部长是威廉·西蒙，他曾是一名纽约市债券推销员。所以，他们非常清楚城市里发生了什么。你会认为，你会认为副总统曾经是我们的州长。财政部长曾经在这里工作。这应该超级容易。
But it's the, instead, it's the exact opposite. It's such a stonewall. And Simon is part of the problem. But another part of the problem is who is running things in the Ford administration and like my stomach hurt when these guys showed up in the movie. It's Donald Rumsfeld and Dick Cheney. What is going? Like, how many times are they going to pop up in the government and wreck things and just do bad stuff? Like, they're just such bad guys, you know?
但事实恰恰相反。这简直是一堵墙。西蒙是问题的一部分。但问题的另一部分是福特政府中谁在掌权，当这些家伙出现在电影中时，我的胃都疼了。是唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德和迪克·切尼。这是怎么回事？他们要在政府中出现多少次并破坏事情，只做坏事？他们真是太坏了，你知道吗？
It was like, I don't know if you had the same reaction I did Roman, but it was literally like as soon as they showed up on screen looking young and smiling because they're doing, they're hurting people and they love it. I was like, oh, these guys, like, how do they keep doing? These bad pennies keep turning up. It's totally right. It's like watching the Star Wars prequels. And you see like, you know, like Senator Palpatine walking across and you're like, I know what you're going to. I know what's going to happen now. Yeah.
就像，我不知道你是否有和我一样的反应，罗曼，但当他们出现在屏幕上，看起来年轻且微笑着，因为他们在伤害别人并且乐在其中时，我简直是，哦，这些家伙，他们怎么一直这样？这些坏钱币总是不断出现。完全正确。这就像看《星球大战》前传。你看到帕尔帕廷议员走过，你会想，我知道你要做什么了。我知道现在会发生什么。是的。
More on Drop Dead City after the break. We're back with Elliot Kalin talking about the documentary Drop Dead City. So when we left New York, it was 1975, and the city was trying to claw its way out of a catastrophic financial crisis. The federal government did not want to help. And so the city is stuck sort of negotiating between the bankers who want deep cuts to services and the city workers who want their jobs. And so you end up in this cycle of the city constantly firing people, cutting services, strikes happening because the U.S. unions are mad because of the services, talks between the bankers and the city, talks between the unions and the city, and the formation of different schemes to try to reorganize the city's
休息后继续讨论《死城》。我们回来了，和埃利奥特·卡林讨论纪录片《死城》。所以当我们离开纽约时，是1975年，城市正试图从一场灾难性的金融危机中挣扎出来。联邦政府不想提供帮助。所以城市陷入了在想要大幅削减服务的银行家和想要保住工作的城市工人之间进行谈判的困境。最终你陷入了一个循环：城市不断解雇员工、削减服务、因为工会不满服务而发生罢工、银行家与城市之间的谈判、工会与城市之间的谈判，以及为了重组城市财政而制定的各种计划。
finances. And the big one is Mac, the municipal assistance corporation, under the oversight of Chairman Felix, Roe-H-R-H-A-T-Y-N, and I always cannot quite, his name is spelled R-O-H-A-T-Y-N, and I always have trouble pronouncing it in my head. You know, in the movie, they say it a couple of different ways, but I sort of make it rhyme with Manhattan, Felix for a hat. Oh, that's really nice. That's a good way to do it.
其中最主要的是MAC，即市政援助公司，在主席菲利克斯·罗哈廷（Felix Rohatyn）的监督下，他的名字拼写是R-O-H-A-T-Y-N，我脑子里总是很难发音。你知道，在电影里，他们说了几种不同的方式，但我让它和曼哈顿押韵，菲利克斯·罗哈廷。哦，那真不错。这是一个好方法。
And at this point, if you wanted to put it into political cartoon terms, it becomes, in some ways, the bankers versus the unions, where the bankers are saying, you need to make cuts, you need to make cuts. You need to make cuts. No, no, no, no, no, no, don't make cuts. We're going to go on strike if you do this. And the city is kind of paralyzed in the middle. But it's really more complicated than that because so much of the solution to the problem involves
在这一点上，如果你想用政治漫画的术语来表达，它在某些方面变成了银行家对阵工会，银行家说，你需要削减开支，你需要削减开支。你需要削减开支。不，不，不，不，不，不，不要削减。如果你这样做，我们就罢工。而城市在中间处于瘫痪状态。但这实际上比这复杂得多，因为解决问题的很大一部分涉及
also the unions investing in these bonds as well. which is something that I was not as familiar with and seems very strange to me because it's like, well, now the union pension fund is going to invest in the city that then pays the union workers. And if it works, what a beautiful cycle of money that it can just go in and out of the union pockets and out of the city pockets. But it really shows you, I guess, that the narrative that I was always taught growing up was the city ran out of money because it was too poorly managed and it didn't know what it was doing. And it needed help and it had to cut everything in order to get bankers to, come back and businesses to come back. And it had to become the technotopian, you know, of capitalist world that is right now. But in reality, it's a much more complicated story and one
工会也投资这些债券。这让我不太熟悉，而且对我来说看起来很奇怪，因为这就像，现在工会养老基金要投资于那个支付工会工人工资的城市。如果它奏效了，那是一个多么美丽的资金循环，它可以进出工会口袋和城市口袋。但这确实向我展示了，我想，我从小被教导的叙事是，城市没钱了是因为管理太差，不知道自己在做什么。它需要帮助，必须削减一切才能让银行家回来，让企业回来。它必须成为现在这个资本主义世界的“技术乌托邦”。但实际上，这是一个复杂得多的故事，一个
that didn't come to as clean a conclusion, as it's sometimes told, but also still relied on a lot of different power brokers and power sources having to come together to work together in some way. This whole idea of this municipal assistance corporation is basically there to find, you know, wonky ways to create new kinds of bonds so that maybe if the Mac is sponsoring the bonds of the city, you know, like it has a little bit more confidence in terms of the bankers and they kind of get a few people. This will show the banks that somebody is overseeing the city in a way that's going to keep it honest. And I love also that they need a that they need a great acronym for it and they start calling it Big Mac, which is such a, it's just that
并没有像有时讲述的那样有一个干净的结论，但也仍然依赖于许多不同的权力掮客和权力来源必须以某种方式走到一起合作。这个市政援助公司的整个想法基本上是为了找到，你知道，古怪的方法来创造新型债券，这样如果MAC为城市债券提供担保，你知道，它在银行家眼中就有了一点信心，他们得到了一些人。这将向银行表明，有人正在以一种保持诚实的方式监督城市。而且我也喜欢他们需要一个伟大的缩写，他们开始称之为“巨无霸”（Big Mac），这真是，这只是那个
branding is so important, even in something like this. And the way people perceive things is so important, even as something as seemingly boring and cut and dry as municipal bond confidence, you know. Right. So Big Mac comes in it, begins to diminish mayor being, who's just sort of there for, you know, ceremonial things and is not making the fiscal decisions of the city, which you could argue was like the key decisions of a mayor. And I would say so.
品牌推广非常重要，即使在这样的事情中也是如此。人们感知事物的方式非常重要，即使是像市政债券信心这样看似枯燥和简单的事情。对。所以“巨无霸”进来了，它开始削弱比姆市长，他只是在那里做一些仪式性的事情，并没有做出城市的财政决策，你可以说这是市长的关键决策。我会这么说。
Yeah, I would think so. And then they can't get a break from, you know, like he goes and testifies and from subcommittees where these Alabama senators are like chastising them for their spending habits and stuff like this. It's like the whole place is really, really shaky. Now, what we all have to consider is how the people back in our respective states respond to this. If we're going to help you out, we've got to justify it to them. And right now we're having great difficulty doing it. Now, you noted yourself that New York has the strongest municipal unions in the nation. I suggest that they're too strong. And the salaries are
是的，我也这么认为。然后他们无法从，你知道，他去作证，从那些阿拉巴马州的参议员因为他们的消费习惯而训斥他们的委员会那里得到喘息的机会。这就像整个地方真的非常非常不稳定。现在，我们所有人都必须考虑我们各自州的人民对此有何反应。如果我们打算帮助你们，我们必须向他们证明这一点。而现在我们很难做到这一点。现在，你自己也注意到纽约拥有全国最强大的市政工会。我建议他们太强大了。而且薪水
ordinately high in New York. That feeling that New York needs to be disciplined, that it needs to be punished, that it is a place that can barely hold together and it's full of just the most violent, uncontrollable, liberal scum of the country, which has its incredible layers of racism built into that, you know, that so much of this is black migrants from the south coming up to New York, this is Puerto Ricans coming to New York City, people who are not middle-class white homeowners, that is all built into this, but this idea that someone's got to teach New York a lesson. No, it's the worst. And there's this rise of conservatism. Like, Gerald Ford, I don't have much of impression of him. He was, you know, that whole administration was an unelected administration, you know.
在纽约高得离谱。那种认为纽约需要被管教、需要被惩罚的感觉，认为它是一个几乎无法维持下去的地方，充满了全国最暴力、不可控的自由派人渣，这其中包含了令人难以置信的种族主义色彩，你知道，这其中很大一部分是来自南方的黑人移民来到纽约，这是波多黎各人来到纽约市，不是中产阶级白人房主的人，所有这些都融入其中，但这种认为有人必须给纽约上一课的想法。不，这是最糟糕的。而且保守主义正在兴起。就像，杰拉尔德·福特，我对他没什么印象。他，你知道，整个政府是一个未经选举的政府，你知道。
He was, I'll give you the Reader's Digest version of Gerald Ford. Gerald Ford, well-meaning guy, not particularly ideological, but very kind of like, well, everyone's got to follow a budget. He loves budgets and he doesn't like the idea of spending, very athletic, incredibly athletic, probably the most athletic president we've ever had, could have played professional ball, football, that is. But, yeah, unelected to where he is. And the feeling I always get from him is someone who is not really equipped to handle the job that he is doing. He's not an idiot, but that he is struggling more because he does not have a real strong ideological bearing. And so when this is all happening with New York City, what's really in the back of his mind, other than New York needs to be taught a lesson because everyone needs to live within a budget, is I know in 1976 I'm going to face Ronald Reagan in a presidential primary. That's right. And Ronald Reagan is going to say, we need to cut taxes and we need to cut services. So I got to outflank him on the right. And it just shows you how any decision made by someone in an elected federal office is partly about the decision and partly about how is this going to affect me in the next election. And I think it can't be understated how much Cheryl Ford was taking a cue from the people who worked for him, who were much more conservative than he was, and also attempting to set himself up, not as I'm the Republican presidential candidate who saved New York by giving it an unlimited lifeline of money, the city that all of us conservatives hate, but instead how he's trying to kind of out Reagan,
他，我会给你杰拉尔德·福特的《读者文摘》版本。杰拉尔德·福特，好心人，不是特别有意识形态，但非常像是，好吧，每个人都必须遵守预算。他喜欢预算，不喜欢消费的想法，非常运动，极其运动，可能是我们有史以来最运动的总统，本可以打职业球，橄榄球。但是，是的，他所在的位置未经选举。我从他身上得到的总是那种没有真正准备好处理他正在做的工作的人的感觉。他不是白痴，但他挣扎得更多，因为他没有一个真正强大的意识形态立场。所以当这一切发生在纽约市时，他脑子里真正想的，除了纽约需要被上一课，因为每个人都需要在预算内生活之外，是我知道在1976年我将在总统初选中面对罗纳德·里根。没错。而罗纳德·里根会说，我们需要减税，我们需要削减服务。所以我必须在右翼上超越他。这只是向你展示了任何由民选联邦官员做出的决定，部分是关于决定本身，部分是关于这将在下次选举中如何影响我。我认为怎么强调都不为过，杰拉尔德·福特在多大程度上听取了为他工作的人的意见，他们比他保守得多，也试图将自己定位，不是作为那个通过给予无限资金救助纽约的共和党总统候选人，那个我们所有保守派都讨厌的城市，而是他试图在那个时刻超越里根。而且他并没有以最圆滑的方式做到这一点。在纪录片中，福特的通讯主管大卫·格根说他接到一个电话，要为福特写一篇演讲，解释为什么他不支持对纽约市的任何帮助。我有种印象，福特想要一篇强硬的演讲。所以我写了一篇非常强硬的演讲，并把它送了过去，理解它会被分发下去，而分发过程中发生的事情
Reagan in that moment. And he doesn't do it in the most tactful way. In the documentary Ford's communications director, David Gurgan says he got a call to write a speech for Ford explaining why he would not support any help to New York City. I had the impression that Ford wanted a hardline speech. So I wrote a very hard-headed speech. and sent it over with the understanding it was going to be staffed out and what happens in the staffing
现在是它被淡化了。当他发表演讲时，我感到震惊。纽约市财务问题的责任被留在了联邦政府的前门，被其真正的父母所抛弃和遗弃。
now is it gets watered down. I was shocked when he gave a speech. Responsibility for New York City's financial problems is being left on the front doorstep of the federal government, unwanted and abandoned
我可以告诉你，现在告诉你，我准备否决任何旨在联邦救助纽约市以防止违约的法案。我从根本上反对这种所谓的解决方案。福特在1975年10月29日发表了这篇演讲，第二天，《纽约每日新闻》刊登了一篇头版故事，标题是“福特对城市说：去死吧”。当然，福特从未说过那些确切的词，就像真的任何类似那些词的话，但这并不重要。
by its real parents. I can tell you and tell you now that I am prepared to veto any bill that has as its purpose a federal bailout of New York City to prevent a default. I am fundamentally opposed to this so-called solution. Ford gives this speech on October 29, 1975, and the next day, the New York Daily News, runs a front-page story with the headline, Ford to City, drop dead. Of course, Ford never said those exact words, like really anything like those words, but it did not matter.
当它通过《纽约每日新闻》的翻译机时，我们最终得到了标题“福特对城市说：去死吧”，这真是，我的意思是，当你想到美国历史上最伟大的报纸标题时，就像，人走上月球，杜威击败杜鲁门，而杜威击败杜鲁门只是因为那张伟大的照片才被记住，因为他们错了，还有福特对城市说去死吧。然后我想是《邮报》有“无头尸体在无上装酒吧被发现”，这是有史以来最伟大的纽约报纸标题之一。但这个标题让纽约人感觉它如此捕捉到了他们从联邦政府那里得到的感觉。它在纽约人的心目中玷污了福特的回应的想法，以至于你可以争论它是否公平。但我会说这是一个伟大的标题。所以我没意见。这确实是一个你看到新闻力量的时刻，因为关于福特的强硬演讲和《纽约每日新闻》的“福特对城市说去死吧”标题，最迷人的一点是，在某种程度上，我认为它创造了这种城市对这种重击的反应，并因此团结在一起。就像它确实产生了强大的影响，因为突然之间，纽约就像是，纽约就像是，
When it was run through the New York Daily News translation machine, we end up with the headline Ford to City dropped dead, which is such, I mean, when you think about the greatest headlines in American history and newspaper, it's like, man walks on moon, do we defeats Truman, and Dewey defeats Truman just gets in because it's that great picture, because they were wrong, and Ford to City dropped dead. And then I think it was the Post had headless body found in Topless Bar, which is one of the all-time great New York newspaper headlines. But the fact that this headline felt to New Yorkers, like it so captured the feeling they were getting from the federal government. And it's so tainted the idea of Ford's response in the minds of New Yorkers in a way that you can argue whether it was fair or not. But I will say it's a great headline. So I'm okay with it. It's really a moment where you see the power of journalism because one of the things that's so fascinating about the Ford, like, tough speech and the New York Daily News is Ford to City drop dead headline is that in a way, I think it creates this like the city reacts to this gut punch and kind of pulls together because of it. Like it really has a powerful impact because all of a sudden it's like New York is like, New York is like,
去你的，是的，基本上就是“去死吧”，不，不，不，不，福特总统去死吧，这太神奇了，我的意思是，这表明，我觉得这就像坏人在动作电影里总是说的那种话，如果你们想把人们团结在一起
a fuck you yeah basically it's just a drop dead me no no no no no present for it drop dead you and there's a it's amazing I mean it guess it goes to show I feel like this is the kind of thing that bad guys say in action movies all the time where they're like if you want to bring people together
给他们一个可以憎恨的恶棍，感觉这些纽约人正如电影所呈现的那样，都在互相攻击，劳工对资本不满，不同的人对其他不同的人不满，那些没有得到垃圾清理服务的人对罢工者不满
give them a villain to hate and it feels like these New Yorkers are all at each other's throats as the movie presents in a way labor is mad at capital and different people are mad at other different people and the people who aren't who are not getting the garbage picked up or mad at the strikers
诸如此类，然后一旦福特进来并说，不，整个城市，我不会帮助你们。你们很臭。每个人都对他感到愤怒，这确实把他们拉到了一起。这就像，我想我们都记得，
and things like that and then once Ford comes in and says, no, the whole city, I'm not going to help you. You stink. Everyone gets mad at him, and it does draw them together a little bit. It's like the end of, I think we all remember,
《蜘蛛侠》的结尾，萨姆·雷米的电影，人们可能不喜欢那个爬墙的人，但一旦他们看到绿魔攻击一辆装满孩子的电车，他们就知道他们必须向他扔管子、垃圾之类的东西。因为它是，我认为这确实帮助他们
the end of Spider-Man, the Sam Ramey film, where people may not like the wallcrawler, but as soon as they see the Green Goblin attacking a tram full of kids, they know they have to throw pipes and garbage and things at him. Because it's, I think it does help them
意识到，至少，哦，如果我们想度过难关，我们就不能在自己人之间争斗，至少不能像以前那样，而且政府不会帮助我们，除非我们以某种方式向他们展示为什么他们需要帮助我们。因为最终，这对我来说是整个过程中最疯狂的事情。最终，联邦政府确实向城市提供了帮助。它提供了，它提供了某种贷款来支持纽约最初的资金问题，以便他们最终能随着时间的推移从这个问题中解脱出来，而且仍然有紧缩削减。这仍然不愉快，城市仍然以这种方式转型，这可能更安全，但从长远来看，没那么有趣，你知道。
to realize, at the very least, oh, we can't fight among ourselves if we're going to get through this, at least not the same way before, and that the government is not going to help us unless we show them in a way why they need to help us. Because eventually, this is to me is the craziest thing about the whole process. Eventually, the federal government does provide help to the city. It provides, it provides kind of loans to back up New York's initial funding problems so that they can dig their way out of this problem eventually over time and there's still austerity cuts. It's still not pleasant and the city still transforms in this way that is probably safer but less fun, you know, in the long run.
但你开始思考，好吧，如果联邦政府早几个月这样做，那么事情可能就不会变得那么糟糕。相反，每个人都陷入了这种必须证明自己是对的境地，你知道，这感觉，我觉得任何两个家伙发生争吵，最后他们的妻子不得不告诉他们，或者也许这更像是一部情景喜剧而不是电影，他们的妻子不得不告诉他们，你们都太专注于证明自己是对的，以至于你们看不到你们需要互相帮助，你知道，你们真的需要彼此。这就是看起来的样子，因为它的另一个潜在论点是，美国真的需要纽约市吗？纽约市像它认为的那样重要吗？美国能在不让其多年来已经投资这些纽约债券的地区性银行崩溃、不让国际商业崩溃、不让其他国家看到美国正在崩溃的情况下给纽约上一课吗？就像，这是在冷战期间。而且这种想法是，美国
But you start to think about, well, if the federal government had just done this months earlier, then things probably wouldn't have gotten as bad. Instead, everyone was in this kind of like had to show that they were right, you know, it feels, I feel like any, any movie where two guys get into an argument and then at the end their wives have to tell, or maybe it's a sitcom more than a movie, their wives have to tell them, you were both so focused on being right that you couldn't see that you needed to help each other, you know, that you really. need each other. And that's what it seems like, because another underlying argument of it is, does America really need New York City? Is New York City as important as it thinks it is? And can the United States teach New York a lesson without its own regional banks that have already invested in these New York bonds over the years without them falling apart, without international business falling apart, without the other countries seeing America as crumbling? Like, this is during the Cold War. And it's the idea that the United States,
会允许其最大的城市违约并破产，而俄罗斯不会对此大加利用，这也是一件令人惊奇的事情。我的意思是，这是很大一部分，你知道，就像福特发表演讲后，你知道，突然之间人们开始做账，他们就像，哦，你知道吗，不仅仅是纽约内部的个人债券持有人会持有这些违约债券，并拥有某种毫无价值的纸张。全国各地的数百家银行都会拥有这些东西，它们会违约。然后其他国家的数百家银行也会有这些违约。每个人都拥有纽约市繁荣的一部分。德国的国家元首甚至对福特说，你不是真的要让这种情况发生，是吗？这对每个人来说都会非常糟糕。然后一切都变了。
would allow its largest city to just default and go bankrupt, and that Russia would not have a field day with that is also an amazing thing. I mean, that's a huge part of, you know, like after Ford gives the speech, you know, all of a sudden people start doing the books and they go like, oh, you know what, it's not just like individual bondholders inside of New York that are going to have these defaulted bonds on there and just like have kind of worthless paper. Hundreds of banks around the country are going to have these things and they're going to default. And then hundreds of banks in other countries are going to have these defaults. Everyone owns a piece of New York City's prosperity. Literally the head of state of Germany is saying to Ford, like, you're not really going to let this happen, are you? This would be really bad for everybody. And everything changes.
突然之间，所有这些建立起来的系统，你知道，有点难以获得牵引力，最终，就像人们意识到，这需要被解决。所以，奥尔巴尼决定在两党基础上增加税收，而且，你知道，城市削减服务，菲利克斯·罗哈廷希望监督这一点。他与各方交谈，因为他能看到这一切的各个方面。他把人们聚集在一起。福特承诺了一堆贷款。最后一点是工会购买了MAC债券。他们拿出养老金，投资于城市。
And all of a sudden, all these sort of systems that put into place, which, you know, we're kind of having a hard time gaining traction, we're finally, like, people realizing, like, this needs to be solved. So, like, Albany decides on a bipartisan basis to raise taxes, and, you know, the city cuts services, and Felix Rohatton hopes oversee this. He's talking to all sides because he kind of can see all sides of this stuff. He brings people together. Ford promises a bunch of loans. The last little bit is the labor unions buy the MAC bonds. They take their pension money and they invest in the city.
而这最后一点说服工作，尤其是教师工会，你知道，他们有点被……所以，我不知道，他们把教师工会负责人设定得特别好斗，特别是因为教师的工资相当低。他们唯一拥有的是保障。当他们被大量解雇时，他们对城市所做的事情感到非常冒犯。而且，就像在学校里塞进越来越多的学生，比如教室本应有30名学生，却会有60名学生。所以他们真的必须被说服去投资这些债券。但最终，他们做了。而那一系列事情最终在最糟糕的时刻避免了破产，并让他们走上了重置城市服务可以提供什么的道路。
And this last little bit of convincing, especially the teachers union, who, you know, kind of got the. So, I don't know, they sort of set up the head of the teachers' union as particularly kind of truculent when it comes to this stuff, particularly because the teachers are pretty underpaid. And the one thing they have is security. And when they were laid off in great number, they took great offense to what the city was doing. And also, like, packing the schools with more and more students, like classrooms are supposed to have 30 students, would have like 60 students in them. And so they really had to be convinced to invest in these bonds. But in the end, they did. And that sort of set of things finally sort of averted bankruptcy in its worst moments and kind of set them up on the path to, you know, like a reset of what a city services could be offered.
但某种财政偿付能力，我想可能一直持续到今天，虽然很脆弱。这是一个惊人的转折点，《死城》非常生动地呈现了它。从城市曾经的样子到它变成的样子。对于一个在80年代和90年代初在纽约之外长大，然后在90年代末和2000年代在纽约的人来说，看到它，看到这种城市的另一个版本，那个以同样方式不再存在的城市，真是太迷人了。它有残余，你知道，我父母会给我讲故事，或者你可以看关于它的电影。但当你现在走在纽约时，它就是没有那种感觉。它没有那种生动的感觉。纪录片的大部分力量来自于它似乎捕捉到了那种感觉，
But sort of a fiscal solvency that sort of like continues, I think probably tenuously to this day. It's this amazing kind of hinge point and Drop Dead City presents it so viscerally. This hinge point from the city as it was to the city as it became. And it feels to someone who grew up outside of New York in the 80s and then the early 90s and it was in New York in the late 90s and the 2000s, it's just so fascinating to see it, to see this kind of other version of the city, the city that really doesn't exist the same way anymore. There's remnants of it, you know, the city that like my parents would tell me stories about or that you can watch movies about. But when you walk around New York now, it just doesn't have that same feeling. It doesn't have that same visceral feeling. And so much of the strength of the documentary comes to how it seems to capture that feeling,
那种身处一个与现在存在的城市不同的城市的感觉。我希望我能去参观，但我从不确定我真的想住在那里，因为它看起来，它看起来确实是一个非常凄凉的地方。那肯定会是很多。好吧，所以回到权力掮客的讨论，罗伯特·摩西在电影《死城》中没有被提及。我们为了获得全貌而阅读的另一本书是金·菲利普斯-法恩（Kim Phillips-Fine）写的《恐惧之城》。摩西可能被提到过一次。我甚至不记得
that feeling of being in a different city than the one that exists now. I wish I could visit, but I'm never quite sure I actually want to live there because it does seem, it seems like a real dismal place. It would be a lot for sure. Okay, so to bring us back to the power broke discussion, Robert Moses is not mentioned in the movie Drop Dead City. other book that we read sort of like in conjunction with this to get a full picture was this book called Fear City by Kim Phillips Fine. Moses has mentioned maybe once. I don't even remember
这是一个大问题。对我来说，这感觉像是对摩西的刻意去中心化。也许在两个项目中，《权力掮客》和摩西通过《权力掮客》投下的阴影，甚至不是摩西本人，而是通过《权力掮客》，那个阴影在纽约研究中投下得如此沉重，以至于它几乎感觉像是刻意将他放在一边以专注于其他事情。但也可能这只是历史变化速度的标志，纽约和世界变化的速度如此之快，以至于如果当时的人们没有过多地考虑他，我也不会感到惊讶。你知道，纽约是一个快速移动的城市。它总是在变化和自我改造。而在某一点上对它极其重要和至关重要的事情，变成了你奶奶告诉你，而你却说，是啊，是啊，是啊，随便吧，随便吧的事情。
it being a very big deal. That feels like a deliberate, that feels like deliberate decentering of Moses to me. Maybe in both projects that the power broker and Moses shadow through the power broker, not even Moses himself, but through the power broker, that shadow falls so heavily on New York studies that it almost feels like a deliberate setting him aside to focus on other things. But maybe it's also a sign of just how fast history was changing, how fast New York and the world was changing that maybe I wouldn't be surprised if the people at the time were not thinking about him too much. You know, New York is a, it's a fast-moving city. It's always changing and transforming itself. And things that were incredibly important and vital to it at one point become the thing that your grandma's telling you about, that you're like, yeah, yeah, yeah, whatever, whatever.
我们不再处理那个了。我想知道这是否是城市在70年代当时的感受，罗伯特，更多。摩西，摩西，那个卡通动物版本的他，他是一只驼鹿。或者罗伯特·摩西，那会是另一个，那个罗伯特·摩西，也许他当时觉得是旧新闻。而且，我不知道，也许需要另一代人阅读《权力掮客》来重新确立他的统治地位。我不知道，这是一件奇怪的事情。这是公众人物及其记忆像其他一切一样时髦与否的方式。但仅仅因为罗伯特·摩西是我们生活和对纽约思考的中心，因为……
We don't deal with that anymore. And I wonder if that was the way the city felt at the time in the 70s, that Robert, more. Mousis, Mousis, the, the cartoon animal version of him where he's a moose. Or Robert Mousis, that would be the other one, that Robert Moses, maybe he felt like old news at that time. And it, I don't know, maybe it took another generation of reading the Powerbroker to reassert his dominance. I don't know, it's a strange thing. It's the way that public figures and their memories kind of go in and out of fashion as well, just as everything else does. But just because Robert Moses is the center of our lives and our thinking about New York because...
一直都是。我很少有一天不想到它。如果你要把这个放进去，仅仅从经验来看，就像，我们不是专家。我们只是粉丝，我们是，你知道，投入的粉丝。你会把这场危机的任何部分归咎于罗伯特·摩西吗？就像，你认为他应该负责的任何部分，或者，你知道，即使它没有出现在这部电影或这本书中？我很想听听你的看法，罗曼，但首先我会给出我的看法，因为你如此友好地问我，我很感激，我认为是的，当然，罗伯特·摩西，城市里发生的事情中有很多与罗伯特·摩西无关，当他在的时候。《权力掮客》让他看起来如此核心，但与此同时，垃圾清理在《权力掮客》中并没有真正被提及。而那是纽约市的三项重要服务之一。
All the time. It's rare I spend a day where I don't think about it. If you were to put this in, just from the experience, like, we're not experts. We're just like fans and we're, you know, like invested fans in this. Would you place any of this crisis at the feet of Robert Moses? Like, is there any part of this that you think he is responsible for or, you know, like, is a part of this that even if it's not presented in this movie or this book? I'm curious to get your take on a Roman, but first I'll give my take because you so kindly asked me, I appreciate it, that I think so, certainly, that Robert Moses, there's so much in the city that was going on that was not related to Robert Moses when he was around. Like, the power broker makes him seem so central, but at the same time, garbage pickup doesn't really get mentioned in the power broker. And that is one of the three vital services of New York City.
就像警察、消防、垃圾清理。水也在上面。也许那是四项重要服务。紧缩措施中一个奇怪的事情是关于教育是否是重要公共服务，是否必要。但垃圾清理肯定是，因为如果垃圾几天不清理，城市就很恶心。就像一个坑。这太可怕了。但它在《权力掮客》中没有被提及，因为它根本不是他参与的事情。
It's like police fire garbage pickup. Water is on there too. Maybe that's the four vital services. And that's one of the curious things about the austerity measures was the argument over whether education is a vital public service or not, whether it's necessary or not. But certainly garbage pickup is because if the garbage doesn't get picked up for a couple days, the city is disgusting. Like it's like a pit. It's just horrible. And but it doesn't get mentioned to the power broker because it wasn't the thing he was involved with at all.
但请记住，城市不仅仅是大型建设项目，你必须想象他所做的事情。在将城市优先事项从内部服务和居民出行转向建设离开城市或穿过城市的道路，以及他拒绝为城市桥梁支付债券，使得这些通行费永远不能用于其他城市需求，它们总是回到三区大桥管理局，他至少是在建立或促成导致让在纽约市生活变得更困难的条件，这才是问题的核心。如果城市更容易居住，这些服务就不会是必要的，你知道，而且这也导致了城市日常缺乏现金。
But keeping in mind that, that there's more to the city than just massive construction projects, you have to imagine that the things he does. did in terms of moving the city's priorities away from internal services and travel for residents and towards the construction of ways to get out of the city or through the city and ways that he starved public transit of funding for private transit and the ways that he refused to pay off the bonds for the city bridges so that those tolls could never go to other city needs. they would just always go back to the Tribor Authority that he at the very least was setting up or contributing to the conditions that were leading to what was making it harder to live in New York City, which is what this really comes down to. The services would not be necessary if the city was easier to live in, you know, and was also contributing to the city's just lack of spending cash on a daily basis.
你知道，你不能靠三区大桥的通行费来运营一个城市，但如果你需要的话，你可能可以在几天内维持它。我认为那是对的。我认为他那种隔离和孤立三区大桥管理局这个小业务，并将其与纽约的一般运营费用分开的能力。而且真的没有理由，如果你不是那么痴迷于道路，在较小程度上，公园，你不会认为这些流入的资金不能支持公共交通或其他服务，只是意识到这是一种属于纽约的收入流。而纽约应该以它认为最合适的方式使用它，而罗伯特·摩西编写了所有法律并控制了一切，以便他能看到钱去了哪里，以及如何从联邦政府那里获得这些随时可以开工的项目。而且，你知道，你可以说，你知道，也许如果他没有这样做，那可能不会那么有效，人们能够接触到那笔钱并将其用于其他事情。
You know, you can't run a city on the tolls on the Tribro Bridge, but you could probably like keep it afloat for a couple days if you needed to. I think that's right. I think his sort of ability to sequester and isolate this little, like, business of the Tribor Authority and keep it away from the general operating expenses of New York. And there's really no reason why, if you just weren't so obsessed with roads and, to lesser extent, parks, that you wouldn't think that this money coming in could not support public transit or other services and just realize this is an income stream that is part of New York. and New York should use it as it best sees fit, whereas Robert Moses wrote all the laws and controlled everything so that he got to see where that money went to and how to create these shovel-ready projects to get from the feds. And, you know, like, you could say that, you know, maybe that wouldn't have worked as well had he, you know, like people being able to get to that money and use it for other things.
你知道，你不可能仅靠三区大桥的过路费来维持一座城市的运转，但如果需要的话，或许能让它维持几天。我想这是对的。我认为他那种能够将三区大桥管理局的业务隔离出来，使其远离纽约一般运营开支的能力，确实很特别。其实没理由认为，如果你不是那么执着于道路建设，或者在较小程度上执着于公园建设，你就不会想到这些收入本可以支持公共交通或其他服务。只要意识到这是一笔属于纽约的收入来源，纽约就应该以最合适的方式使用它。而罗伯特·摩西制定了所有法律并控制了一切，这样他就能决定资金的去向，以及如何创造这些能从联邦政府获得资金的“即刻动工”项目。你可以说，如果其他人也能接触到这笔钱并将其用于其他用途，或许他的那一套就不会那么奏效了。
But yet that would be great if he didn't get his way. And, you know, maybe a few different highways wouldn't have been built and some money wouldn't have flowed through the system. But that, again, like, if fractions of that had been devoted to the subway system, we wouldn't have the breakdown of the subway system later on, which is a huge part of this crisis in the 70s. And so much of this that I think, you know, he's not responsible for $6 billion of deficit. But had he thought in the totality about the health and welfare of New York and New Yorkers and really had that at the center, of his heart and soul, this place really could have avoided this.
但如果他没能如愿，那其实会很棒。你知道，也许会有几条不同的高速公路不会被修建，一些资金也不会流入那个系统。但话说回来，如果将其中一小部分资金投入到地铁系统中，我们后来就不会面临地铁系统的崩溃，而这正是70年代这场危机的很大一部分原因。我认为他并不需要为60亿美元的赤字负责，但如果他能从整体上考虑纽约和纽约人的健康与福利，并真正将其放在心上，这个地方本可以避免这一切。
I mean, like, it would require a different structure of system, but I feel like he was smart enough that he could figure that out if he just cared about these things. And so I would put a lot, I mean, it's hard to, you know, run the tape back and see how history would have played out had he, you know, been a true New Yorker team player and cared about. As Robert Carroll says, you can't say if New York would be a better city without Robert Moses. It would be a different city, you know. But I do think that there's. a good chance it could have been actually better. If he had all those powers and all that faculty to build and create and make things and also thought about the city as a whole and cared about
我的意思是，这需要一个不同的系统结构，但我感觉他足够聪明，如果他真的关心这些事情，他完全可以想出办法。所以我会投入很多，我的意思是，很难回溯历史，看看如果他是一个真正的纽约团队成员并关心这一切，历史会如何发展。正如罗伯特·卡罗所说，你不能说没有罗伯特·摩西，纽约会成为一个更好的城市。它会成为一个不同的城市。但我确实认为，它很有可能变得更好。如果他拥有所有那些权力、所有那些建设、创造和制造事物的能力，同时也从整体上考虑城市并关心
all the different aspects of who was in the city, I think that there was a tool at the disposal of the city to make this better and maybe not have this crisis happen at all. And Robert Moses could have been that tool, you know. You put your finger on something Roman too that I had forgotten about because I'm so focused on the physical, the tangible, you know, roads, tunnels, bridges, parks, that you're right that you mentioned he wrote the laws. And one of New York's problems was that it could not raise certain taxes unless the state gave it approval.
城市中所有不同的人，我认为城市本可以利用这些工具来改善现状，甚至可能根本不会发生这场危机。而罗伯特·摩西本可以成为那个工具。罗曼，你也指出了我忽略的一点，因为我太专注于物质和有形的东西，比如道路、隧道、桥梁、公园。你说得对，他确实参与了法律的制定。纽约的问题之一是，除非得到州政府的批准，否则它无法提高某些税收。
Like, there were institutional reasons that New York was kind of stuck in doing things the way it was. And he was responsible for at least some of those laws. He wrote the state constitution for New York, right? So he is somewhat responsible for it directly, even just from that. And I think you're right. If he had been writing those laws less to an eye of how do I create little loopholes for myself in the future for doing powerful things and more from a point of view of that earlier Moses that we want to believe in from the beginning of the book who is more idealistic, you know, even if we don't agree with all of his ideals, then perhaps the city would have still found itself in a tight spot but would have had the tools to wriggle out of that type spot without things coming to a head so dramatically and so explosively. the other hand, think about it this way, Roman. If there hadn't been that crisis, what would
就像纽约在做事方式上陷入困境是有制度原因的。而他至少对其中一些法律负有责任。他为纽约州起草了州宪法，对吧？所以即使仅从这一点来看，他也负有直接责任。我认为你是对的。如果他在起草这些法律时，不是为了给自己未来行使权力创造小漏洞，而是从我们书开头想要相信的那个更理想主义的摩西的角度出发——即使我们并不完全同意他的所有理想——那么也许这座城市仍然会陷入困境，但会有工具来摆脱这种困境，而不至于让事情发展到如此戏剧性和爆炸性的地步。另一方面，换个角度想，罗曼，如果没有那场危机，
we be talking about on this episode today? You're not going to do a whole episode on how New York sailed through the 70s fiscal bumpiness, you know? And 50 years later, we would have never met. Yeah, that's true. So really, in a way, everything worked out for the best. Yeah, that's true. Hey, it was fun revisiting the Powerbroker and watching this movie, Drop Dead City. If you haven't watched it already, I really recommend you check it out. If nothing else, just to hear the New Yorkers talking in the 1970s is the greatest thing in the world. And yeah, this is great. Thank you so much, Elliot, for rejoining us. Thank you so much. Anytime you want to talk about New York and how grimy it can get, please have me on. I would really appreciate it.
我们今天这集节目要聊什么呢？你总不能做一整集关于纽约如何平稳度过70年代财政动荡的节目吧？50年后，我们也不会相遇。是的，那倒是真的。所以从某种意义上说，一切都是最好的安排。没错。嘿，重温《权力掮客》并观看这部电影《死城》很有趣。如果你还没看过，我强烈推荐你去看看。退一步说，光是听70年代纽约人的谈话就是世界上最棒的事情了。是的，这太棒了。非常感谢埃利奥特再次加入我们。非常感谢。任何时候你想聊聊纽约以及它有多么肮脏，请务必邀请我。我会非常感激的。
Drop dead city comes out on VOD on November 14th. And if you live in New York, there are a bunch of screenings coming up. You can find out more at drop dead city, themovie.com. And if you're interested in 1970s, New York, but never got around to listening to our powerbroker Breakdown series, then do yourself a favor. Scroll back up in the 99PI feed to December 2023 and hit play every time you see the words, The Power Broker. You can enjoy it, whether you're reading along or not, and Ellie and I talk with a bunch of great guests, including Conan O'Brien, AOC, Pete Buttigieg, and the man himself, Robert
《死城》将于11月14日以视频点播形式上映。如果你住在纽约，接下来会有很多放映活动。你可以在dropdeadcitythemovie.com了解更多信息。如果你对70年代的纽约感兴趣，但还没来得及听我们的《权力掮客》深度解析系列，那就帮自己一个忙。在99PI的订阅源中向后滚动到2023年12月，每次看到“权力掮客”字样就点击播放。无论你是否在阅读原著，你都能享受其中。我和埃利与许多优秀的嘉宾进行了交谈，包括柯南·奥布莱恩、AOC、皮特·布蒂吉格，以及罗伯特本人。
Caro. This episode was produced by me and Isabel Angel, music by Swan Real, Mix by Martin Gonzalez. 99% of Visible's executive producer is Kathy 2, our senior editor. is Delaney Hall. Kurt Koolstead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Christopher Rubei, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lashemadon, Jacob Medina Gleason, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Series XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show
本集由我和伊莎贝尔·安吉尔制作，音乐由斯旺·里尔创作，混音由马丁·冈萨雷斯完成。《99%无形》的执行制片人是凯西·图，我们的高级编辑是德莱尼·霍尔。库尔特·库尔斯特德是数字总监。团队其他成员包括克里斯托弗·鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·莱、拉舍马顿、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森、凯利·普莱姆、乔·罗森伯格，以及我，罗曼·马斯。《99%无形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是SiriusXM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在
on all the usual social media sites as well as your own Discord server, where we have fun discussions about constitutional law again. We have conversations about architecture, movies, music, and all kinds of good stuff. It's where I'm hanging out most these days. You can find a link to the Discord server as well as every past episode of 99PI and the powerbroker breakdown at 99PI.org.
所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到我们的节目，以及我们自己的Discord服务器，在那里我们再次愉快地讨论宪法。我们讨论建筑、电影、音乐和各种好东西。这是我最近待得最多的地方。你可以在99PI.org找到Discord服务器的链接，以及《99%无形》和《权力掮客》深度解析的每一期往期节目。
You can have you talk about Philadelphia, too. You can insult Philadelphia. I can't believe we got through a whole episode without me insulting Philadelphia. You've got a world-class art museum. world class. You stick a statue of Sylvester Stallone on the steps? What are you doing? Philly, what are you doing? What are you doing, Philly? There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你也可以聊聊费城。你可以侮辱费城。我简直不敢相信我们竟然在没有我侮辱费城的情况下完成了一整集节目。你们有一个世界级的艺术博物馆。世界级的。你们竟然在台阶上放了一尊西尔维斯特·史泰龙的雕像？你们在干什么？费城，你们在干什么？费城，你们在干什么？本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。